estábamos construyendo la fórmula del
rotacional en tres dimensiones y donde
nos quedamos fue con este determinante
de 3 por 3 que en realidad parece
absurdo de calcular verdad porque casi
nada de lo que tenemos aquí parecen
números pero pero siguiendo la idea de
lo que es el determinante llegaremos a
una función vectorial que corresponde al
rotacional en tres dimensiones así que
vamos a hacernos un pequeño espacio por
acá para seguir con las cuentas y vamos
a calcular digamos este determinante
verdad entonces como calculamos el
determinante es considerar esta primera
entrada y luego la multiplicamos por el
determinante de esta sub matriz que
resulta de quitar la columna y la fila
correspondiente a esta entrada verdad
entonces lo que tendríamos serían los
siguientes sería el vector y que
multiplica al determinante de esta
verdad pero sería la derivada parcial
con respecto de y de nuestra función r
menos la derivada parcial de zeta común
de nuestra función
verdad de nuestra función q y eso
corresponde a nuestro primer término y
ahora vamos a seguir con el segundo
término correspondiente a j yx recuerden
que cuando calculamos el determinante
pensamos como una alternancia de signos
verdad tendríamos más menos más y
entonces tendríamos menos nuestro vector
jota verdad y multiplicamos por la
matriz que por el determinante de la
matriz más bien que resulta de quitar la
fila y la columna de jota verdad
entonces en realidad tendríamos estas
esta sub matriz generada por estos
cuatro elementos digamos y entonces el
determinante sería la parcial con
respecto de x de r
r - la parcial de z la parcial con
respecto de z de nuestra función p muy
bien entonces esto sería el segundo
término y el tercer término sería
tomando ahora nuestro vector que
multiplicando por el determinante de
esta sub matriz verdad entonces
tendríamos acá que multiplica a la
derivada parcial con respecto de x de
nuestra función q verdad de nuestra
función q menos la derivada parcial de
con respecto de y la derivada parcial
con respecto de y de nuestra función p
bien y entonces esto que hemos obtenido
aquí es justamente la fórmula del
rotacional en tres dimensiones para este
campo vectorial b que teníamos
inicialmente con tres entradas que
llamamos pq y r
y en realidad aquí digamos lo tenemos
con la anotación con vectores y jk
verdad que son vectores unitarios pero
si queremos escribirlo en términos
y un vector columna entonces lo
escribiríamos más o menos algo así
tendríamos que el rotacional de nuestro
vector b en nuestro campo vectorial b
evaluada en el punto x 10 eta sería en
realidad este vector con tres
componentes verdad y la primera
componente sería la que corresponde al
vector i es decir tendríamos la parcial
con respecto de jbr menos la parcial con
respecto de z de nuestra función q y por
supuesto todo esto está evaluado en x y
z y pues no voy a terminar esto
simplemente sería poner esta entrada y
esta es otra entrada aquí verdad sólo
teniendo cuidado con este signo entonces
en realidad cualquiera de las dos
anotaciones es correcta yo prefiero
utilizar la anotación del vector columna
quizás a otras personas les guste más
utilizar y j y que en realidad no
importa siempre y cuando sepas ir de una
a la otra
ahora bien algo que quisiera notar de
esta fórmula que hemos obtenido es esta
última parte que tenemos aquí si
observamos muy bien esto es justamente
la fórmula del rotacional en dos
dimensiones verdad esto es digamos
pensando en un campo vectorial que se
encuentra en el plano xy esta es la
fórmula del rotacional en dos
dimensiones y vemos que va en la
dirección del vector
cada verdad que es que es el que apunta
en la dirección vertical o en la
dirección del eje z verdad y eso ya lo
habíamos visto en un vídeo anterior y si
observamos en estos otros términos de
aquí obtenemos cosas similares verdad
entonces si pensamos por ejemplo en la
rotación en el plano xy digamos es
justamente lo que tenemos aquí verdad y
eso se da con un vector que va en la
dirección de este vector acá y si esto
te parece quizás algo raro te recomiendo
que vayas al vídeo que habla de este
tema verdad de la rotación de campos
vectoriales en dos dimensiones cuando
los metemos en tres dimensiones
los otros dos términos son digamos
términos similares verdad aquí
estaríamos pensando en la rotación en el
plano x z que nos arroja digamos un
vector en la dirección de j que de hecho
es perpendicular al plano x z y para
este término ocurre algo similar esta es
la rotación en el plano z
y nos arroja un vector en la dirección
de iu que es perpendicular justamente al
plano que se está verdad y cuando lo
calculamos sólo obtenemos digamos una
fórmula que en realidad no es que
pensemos siempre digamos en en las
distintas rotaciones en cada plano
verdad pero siempre es bueno reconocer
cuál es la intuición detrás que hay
cuando hablamos de rotaciones en dos
dimensiones y otra cosa que quiero
enfatizar es que en realidad esto no es
una fórmula para memorizar se digo al
menos yo no lo haría si fuera ustedes yo
lo único que haría sería recordar que el
rotacional en realidad está simplemente
descrito con esta verdad con el producto
cruz del operador nabla y el campo
vectorial
de allí digamos sean las componentes que
tengas en realidad no importa puedes
seguir todo este proceso que quizás es
algo largo pero al menos no tienes que
memorizar esta fórmula tan larga verdad
y en el próximo vídeo haré un ejemplo
con funciones particulares digamos pq r
y haremos todo este proceso para el
ejemplo concreto que vamos a ver nos
vemos